how to beat legions of Russian online
trollers and Isis propagandists at their
own game combating v80 fraud to the tune
of 170 billion euros a year and a
filmmaking legend comes to Parliament to
mark a milestone some of the top agenda
items coming up in Parliament in
Brussels next week armies of trolls
distorted narratives campaigns of
misinformation blatantly planted
patently false just some of the modern
tools of information warfare which
Russia and so called Isis stand accused
of using on Monday the Foreign Affairs
Committee pushes bank demanding
increased counter-propaganda efforts
such as closer intelligence cooperation
of support to free media in neighbouring
countries and building up the e use and
NATO's information systems talking of
Russia and it's important energy
supplies to Europe how to improve ways
to protect those member states whose
supplies could be at risk in a crisis
the international trade committee will
vote on options on Thursday including
better cooperation and risk assessment
and as a last resort a compulsory
solidarity clause to support those in
need there'll be a vote in the Economic
Affairs Committee on moves towards a
European dat system it's a long road
strewn with many obstacles put up by
member states and Parliament had wanted
more but it does address v80 fraud which
accounts for an estimated loss of 170
billion euros annually almost a third of
it in cross-border Ford the vote is on
Thursday and now in brief some other
items coming up there's a vote on
Tuesday on the e u--'s 2017 budget in
the budgets committee key focus
migration terrorism and organized crime
the digital single market and energy
Union also the Harlan Affairs Committee
joins human rights and development
colleagues to select the shortlist for
this year's sakharov prize for freedom
of thought on Monday and Tuesday the
fisheries committee debates several
measures to protect fish stocks and
marine ecosystems in seas near and far
to say the economic affairs committee
votes on the European Central Bank's
2000
15 report one demand of many watch out
for housing bubbles due to rock-bottom
interest rates the annual locks price
celebrating the work of outstanding
filmmakers in the EU is a landmark event
in the cultural calendar it's about
encouraging talent and sharing Europe's
diversity of culture and language
geography and history and to mark 10
years of the prize the acclaimed British
film director in loge will be in
Brussels on Monday to exchange views
with members of Parliament's cultural
committee one to look out for for sure
in the coming parliamentary week in
Brussels